the Joe Rogan experience they were just
sewing these seeds of discourse or
discord all throughout social medias
wonderful wacky social media page this
is kind of hilarious yeah the more
discord the better but it's of course
it's going to happen as soon as the
government realized that if you rile
people enough enough they'll engage and
then they'll you can actually shift
opinion yeah yeah especially if you're
funny yes that's that's one of the
things about all these funny memes oh
yeah oh my god there that's I mean this
is this is why I'm very scared for the
Democrats because Joe Biden is might be
the nominee he does not have a good
social media team when when he had this
family photo for Halloween all I just
replied with a photo of a crack pipe
right and where's hunter hashtag was
trending and I'm like no matter what you
think of Joe Biden it is not acceptable
for his Twitter not to be able to handle
this and anticipate it especially
because you have someone who just
tweeted his way into the presidency
three years ago
yes like where are the people who are
helping this guy you know with his
social media game yeah they can't help
them the the people that are mean and
funny like that are all Republicans this
is something about the beams that go
against Trump versus the means that go
for Trump like the pro Trump memes are
so much funnier yeah the left can't meme
is the thing not that good another good
one of my sameen kind of humor one of my
tweets became a meme when your girl
Tulsi took out officer Harris and I said
if there's one thing Hawaii knows its
how to roast a pig and that went wide ah
I wonder if she knows about that she
knows shows she she knows she see it she
saw it she saw you know she's because I
send it to me and I'll make sure she
sees it okay please I will I don't send
it to her her chief of communications
would never follows me on Twitter oh
yeah yeah perfect yeah she's good I like
her well I'd like her as a person I'm
just glad that now that Harris is gone
it's just gonna be hilarious for the
next year whoever it is well the Harris
thing was weird men did like that they
didn't know the stuff that you could
call her out on oh yeah that come on
that tulsi did but Tulsi didn't even get
to the horrible stuff the horrible stuff
was
when she was threatening single moms
with jail time their kids were truant
right
imagine you're just barely staying above
water as a single mom and you got to
literally make your [ __ ] children
terrified that you're gonna go to jail
in order for them to go to jail she was
laughing about how that's how she got
people to go to jail that's that's how
she got people to go to school and
that's the thing is that I don't think
she actually cared I think this was her
means to further her political career
thank you because when you are you could
say a lot of things about Joe Biden and
I have on Twitter to go on the stage and
call him a closet racist or imply that
come on like this is how she did the
first debate she goes oh you were
against busing and he's like I was
against it on the federal level like
what are you talking about she's like
well I was like who are you fooling you
nasty nasty Pig she's done yeah they're
playing game when she when she dropped
out like the fans chipped in on my
livestream and I spent $400 on ham and I
did a ham tasting cuz the pig was done
oh it was a lot of fun
[Applause]